here's the new x-men apocalypse trailer
who saw that coming escalation at this
point we have new Captain America civil
war trailer well we got a having a balk
loes trailer - but you feel like Fox you
should know you don't want to dilute the
current Sam you get what x-men
apocalypse is going to be because it's
ultimately every trailer everything they
built shall fall from the ashes we'll
build a better one oh we need to fly it
apocalypse gonna tear us up you turds
big every trailer everytime palaver does
looks like fox is listening to fans
because fans were like why is Katniss
so Katniss why isn't she mutant and
proud and actually mistake so this one
there's a lot more blue mystique and
before it looked like they were trying
to hide apocalypse his face because
people called him Ivan ooze and this one
so you see his face a lot more of his
face actually and his voice is a little
different has this robotic twang to it
till turns big and smashes Xavier I'm
pretty sure we see Xavier die yeah dead
I mean we get it at this point it's
x-men apocalypse just bring on the movie
if they come out with another trailer
for x-men apocalypse not gonna show us
anything more than we already know now
it's gonna be the same as this trailer
which is pretty much the same as the
last trailer the trailer does start out
with the Xavier magneto dialogue from
the end of the first x-men movie where
it's like does it ever wake you in the
middle of the night at the thought
they'll come for you and your children
and then Xavier says I feel like great
swole pity for the poor soul coming to
my school looking for trouble unless
he's a big blue Egyptian mutant God who
can turn huge and smash me into a wall
and kill me that sucks that's some cool
Throwdown imagery though that Steemer
havoc like damn shootings just lays
there I was like that's pretty solid
shoot that right up cerebro's ass I
guess I liked it shows Nightcrawler
fighting arc angel I mean anytime
Nightcrawler gets some shine he was
always one of my favorite x-men like in
that double screen arcade game I used to
play Nightcrawler so give Nightcrawler
some shine my point is I can't deny I'm
looking forward to this movie and this
trailer has some great imagery I'm just
saying I feel like at this point this
should be the last trailer we see before
the movie comes out I know there's still
a couple months before the movie comes
out there's going to be another trailer
but there shouldn't be with Fox
it's x-men apocalypse we're gonna watch
it you don't need to give us so many
trailers nothing I'm complaining because
obviously my fans you good people you
always want me to talk about these
trailers and you always watch the videos
of me talking about the trailer so hey
I'll be here to do videos on it I'm just
saying how many times can we say if you
follow blind leaders from the ashes
we'll build a bed
one gross splat fight war x-men
apocalypse Poe Dameron okay so we're all
in agreement this is the last trailer
before the movie comes out now alright
there's gonna be another one holy crap
alright guys so the new x-men apocalypse
trailer have you seen it what did you
think about it what you think of
apocalypse is your face now that they're
actually showing it what do you think of
his new Robo voice that's like the
smoking lady from the 90s commercials
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]